hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar X9 real-time PCR system an
Innovative high capacity genomic system
for Superior efficiency
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by standard biotools to learn more visit
standardbio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them in to the ask
a question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Luca boveri PhD director Global product
management
microfluidic instruments and Michael
Gonzalez PhD director of systems
integration Luca and Michael you now may
begin your presentation
foreign
for joining us today at standard
biotools our purpose is to accelerate
breakthrough in a human health by
providing the right research tools that
can help our customer to generate
reliable and repeatable insights
we are excited today to introduce you to
our new X9 real-time PCR system the X9
real-time PCR system is built to deliver
high-capacity genomic analytical
capabilities and Superior efficiency and
efficacy to support Laboratories across
all the phases of their Discovery
Journal
this Innovative and unique platform is
empowered by standard biotools proven
and proprietary microfluidic technology
that enable researchers and scientists
to obtain more data and insights with
less efforts
standard biotools integrated fluid is
Circus circuit or IFC technology Empower
life science research by automating PCR
reaction in Nano leader volumes to
deliver cost-effectiveness
enabling High throughput productivity
with individual reaction Simplicity for
maximum flexibility and versatility
delivering an integrated workflow for
minimal operator contribution
the X9 a real-time PCR system is the
Workhorse needed when Laboratories
demand High productivity
X9 is capable of exceptional processing
performances both in the case when high
volume sample testing is needed as well
as when large Target plexity is required
the X9 system in combination with
Dynamic array offering is capable to
generate up to
9216 data points in a single run more
than 46 000 results in a work shift and
simultaneous individual identification
of up to 96 targets with no need for
complex simple single well multiplexing
setups
the X9 is a standalone system that does
not require any ancillary platform
all the processes that includes priming
of the dynamic array IFC reaction setup
and real-time PCR or endpoint reading
are integrated and Consolidated in a
unique workflow that take place
automatically at the price of one single
button
the intuitive and user-friendly
interface enables in immediate
implementation in the laboratory routine
and workflow with minimal training of
the operator that can quickly operate
the system with confidence
the fully integrated workflow reduces
operator contribution to help maximizing
the use of laboratory resources and
minimizing human error
X9 system is characterized by Standalone
capabilities with no need of a computer
attached platform and in conjunction
with a small footprint enables
Laboratories to ensure best space
utilization
the analysis of the data can be easily
conducted on a separate computer
everywhere
the powerful standard biotools real-time
PCR software package supports large data
analysis for multiple applications with
color-coded expressionit maps allele
maps and cluster plots for single or
multiple runs
the integrated fluidic circuit or IFC
forms the backbone of the X9 system
supporting different configuration of
sample and assays for multiple
applications
each Dynamic array IFC is a Precision
manufactured to exact standard of
performance and reliability
Dynamic array ifcs Empower genomic
research by automating PCR reaction
setup and real-time PCR processing in
non-leader volumes
please reduce reaction volume
resulting in using less of your precious
sample and assay reagents and helping
lowering the cost while keep achieving
high quality consistent results
by adopting different Dynamic array
formats that are characterized by
different samples to Target ratio or by
integrated additional capabilities such
as a preamplification step the user can
instantly
adapt to laboratory immediate
experimental needs with no Hardware
changes required for example for a high
sample throughput and midplexity the
operator can select the 19224 dynamic
array format that can process up to
1152 samples per 8 hour working shift
and have each samples interrogated for
up to 24 Assa peram
or in the case preamplification is
needed for example when the sample
starting quantity scars the user can
immediately shift to use 9696 preamp
ifcx that integrates the
preamplification capabilities automated
into the workflow when Superior data
generation capacity is required the
scientists can switch to 9696 Dynamic
array that by generating more than 46
000 results per shift and the 96 assays
interrogated per sample per run supports
a deeper sample profiling and a greater
insights into the model that is studied
when a lower data output is required for
example in the early phase of Discovery
or low volume testing season the user
can adapt adopt a 4848 Dynamic array
format that can process up to 848
samples and approximately 2 300 data
points per batch
the X9 system in conjunction with a
dynamic array supports the most popular
applications including genotyping and
snip detection gene expression and
relative quantification pathogen
detection and present substance and copy
number variation
the system is compatible with the most
common chemistries on the market and
supports development and creation of
custom assays creating a wide range of
testing and investigation options
X9 is compatible with Advanta sample ID
panel the sample ID panel supports
biobank and genomic centers by providing
a high throughput solution for molecular
sample identification enabling to
simultaneously perform molecular
fingerprinting quality assessment and
integrity confirmation on every sample
X9 also supports our standard biotools
recent release
pharmacogenomic panel that allow to
process Snips and cmvs from up to 96
sample in a single workflow with the
option of using extraction free buccal
swabs achieving results in approximately
approximately 4 hours with actionable
content that can be customized to meet
your needs if you want to learn more
about standard biotool pharmacogenomic
panel we invite you to join the upcoming
dedicated webinar contacted by my
colleague billand on this same channel
on November 30th or to visit our website
integrated fluidic circuit technology is
the core of standard biotools
microfluidic solution
these unique and proprietary technology
has been proven on the market with
hundreds of Publications since the
release of our first microfluidic
platform in 2006.
standard biotools microfluidic approach
empowers you to easily tailor a genomic
analysis approach that is well suited
suited to you to your goal and an
objective
automated reaction setup minimize
operator contribution and reduces human
error Multiplex data output with a
single plexus Simplicity enables you to
instantly add or remove Target and
assays to immediately respond to
experimental needs
miniaturization of the reaction setup
reduces experimental cost of reagents
and consumable utilization
in regards of these uh last point
when compared to Conventional real-time
PCR micro title based approach X9 and
IFC technology can definitely deliver
incredible advantage to Laboratories
looking to minimize cost while still
supporting their high throughput and
high capacity needs and this is an
example in order to provide the same
data output of a single 9696 format the
dynamic arrayfc the user would need 96
individual 96 well microtighter plates
the cost advantage in terms of region
consumption is evident as well as the
reduced plastic consumption but I also
invite you to think in terms of time to
results
with our 96 96 format we are able to
obtain
9216 data points that is 96 sample
interrogated for 96 independent assays
in 1 hour and 35 minutes for gene
expression application and Below 1 hour
and 45 minutes for a genotyping
okay
X9 real-time PCR system well fitting
multiple and diverse research areas and
laboratory settings
the high throughput and high capacity
capabilities in conjunction with a
streamlined workflow supports the need
of high volume routine testing in areas
like agricultural genomic or
biotechnology and fisheries management
Pi throughput sample identification with
Advanta sample ID in conjunction with
integrated reaction setup and X9 system
automated operations benefits genomic
Center bio repositories and centralized
cell line Banks ensuring accurate sample
tracking on quality from acquisition
through data reporting
flexibility of
format and configuration in conjunction
with the capability to easily switch
across application enables Research
Laboratories to easily adapt to changing
experimental needs
now Michael Gonzalez will now take the
stage and introduce you to the tech more
technical aspects related to external
time PCR system and standard value tools
microfluidic technology
okay thanks Luca at this time I would
like to go into a little bit more detail
about microfluidic PCR the benefits it
can provide and how it is implemented on
the X9 system
the standard bio tool system uses our
Dynamic array ifcs to automatically
assemble individual nanometer scale PCR
reactions
on the dynamic or aifc reaction assembly
starts with the transfer of samples and
assays to the nanoliter scale sample and
assay Chambers shown in the diagram to
the right
each pair of Chambers can then be
isolated and mixed to assemble an
independent single Plex real-time PCR
reaction
up to 96 individual reactions can be
assembled per sample each with a
different real-time PCR Target
after assembly of reactions the X9
system automatically proceeds to Thermal
cycling and data collection
the X9 system with dynamic or aifcs
enables automated assembly of up to 9216
individual nanometer scale real-time PCR
reactions with minimal Hands-On time and
pipetting while allowing for
maximization of efficiency and cost
saving through reduced reagent volumes
microfluidic real-time PCR offers a
number of benefits over methods that use
96 or 384 well plates
one major advantage is the number of
samples and targets that can be
processed in a single run
with plant-based real-time PCR the
number of targets is typically limited
to at most six per sample per sample
reaction
any additional targets would require
additional reactions with the same
sample
using dynamic or aifcs on the X9 system
up to 96 targets can be assessed per
sample with up to 96 samples per run
this means
that it would take at least 16 96 weld
plates each run with a six Plex
Multiplex reaction to generate the same
amount of data that can be obtained from
a single run on the X9 system
this is the best case scenario and
assumes that all reactions could be run
as six Flex reactions in reality This is
highly unlikely is Multiplex real-time
PCR reactions require extensive
optimization that often demands
compromises between performance and
Target throughput
unlike plate bait approaches however
Dynamic arrays assemble each reaction as
a single Plex reaction eliminating the
possibility of adverse assay
interactions and the need for cumbersome
Multiplex optimization studies
additionally because each single Plex
reaction is isolated individual targets
can be easily added changed or
substituted without requiring
re-optimization of the unchanged targets
finally because the X9 system ultimately
uses real-time PCR for its detection it
can provide the same high quality data
expected from plate-based studies
the X9 system allows the use of both
pre-designed and custom Target content
this flexibility allows a wide array of
applications to take advantage of the
higher assay throughput enabled by the
X9 system
examples of applications on the X9
system in various Fields as shown on the
slide and they include but are not
limited to sample identification and
tracking genotyping based
pharmacogenomics gene expression
profiling and pathogen detection
on the X9 system these applications are
executed similarly to their plant-based
analogs but they take advantage of the
increased sample and Target throughput
enabled by microfluidic reactions to
provide much more data than is
practically possible with plate-based
approaches
for example the sample identification
panel is available for use on the X9
system that can enable genomic
identification and tracking of human
samples and biobanks and research
studies using a specifically selected
panel of 96 snips
the ability of the X9 system to assess
all 96 Snips per sample allows confident
assessment of sample identity and
integrity for up to 96 samples at a time
in a single run
to realistically Implement a similar
screening using the plate-based
real-time PCR would require the use of
far fewer targets compromising the
ability to confidently identify samples
or dramatically reduce the sample
throughput to only a few samples per run
another panel available in this case
targeting 74 Snips and CNB loci of genes
involved in metabolic processes permits
pharmacogenomic analysis of up to 96
samples at a time with the Simplicity
and accuracy of real-time PCR based
workflow similar to the previous example
of sample identification panel the X9
system allows the panel to include all
Targets required to generate a complete
picture of the relevant genotypes
without compromising on the number of
samples that can be processed in a
single run
gene expression profiling is another
common application on the X9 system one
example of this is the standard biotools
immuno oncology panel 170 Target panel
to assess the expression of genes
involved in response to
immuno-oncology-based Therapeutics
this type of targeted expression
profiling can generate deep data sets on
large number of samples that would not
be practical with plate-based approaches
all while avoiding the processing and
Analysis infrastructure required for a
sequencing based method to get the same
results
multi-pathogen detection is another
application where microfluidic
approaches can allow deeper analysis
than would be practical with plate-based
PCR
in this case instead of running each
sample through a series of tests and
plates each directed to a specific
pathogen of Interest the X9 system can
be used to run each sample against a
panel of assays targeting all pathogens
of interest in a single run
this permits High sample throughput
without the end user having to switch
assays from run to run
in addition the use of single Plex
microfluidic reactions for this panel
means that individual assets can easily
be added changed or removed based on
changing pathogens
and identities without the need to
re-optimize the remaining unchanged
assets
well these are just some of the
application enabled by the high sample
and target throughput of a microfluidic
PCR on the X9 system they highlight the
diverse array of methods that can be
enabled by this technology
the open nature of content on the
dynamic arrays means that any
application can really take advantage of
the benefits of microfluidic PCR on the
X9 system
the X9 system allows generation of high
density data with results from up to
9216 reactions in a single run this of
course isn't going to be useful unless
there are tools available to easily
analyze this large amount of data
standard biotools analysis software
packages allow for easy analysis of
real-time PCR data from the X9 system
this includes automatic assessment of
amplification quality and threshold
application for CT calling automatic
normalization and Delta Delta CT
calculations for quantitation and gene
expression analysis and automated snip
and cnv genotype following for
genotyping applications all to simplify
the analysis of large data sets
the analysis software also permits
in-depth assessment of results for each
sample displaying amplification curves
and Associated data for each individual
reaction
allow allowing the assessment of
individual reaction performance
if desired analysis parameters can also
be adjusted manually in the same manner
as plate-based real-time PCR giving the
user ultimate control over analysis of
their data
finally result summaries can be exported
to multiple formats allowing for
additional analysis
the X9 system uses micropolitic
reactions to generate high density
real-time PCR data this increase in
throughput is achieved while maintaining
the same high quality performance that's
expected from real-time PCR
the next few slides will demonstrate
some of the key performance parameters
of micropolitic real-time PCR in the X9
system for both gene expression and
genotyping Analysis
accurate discrimination of differences
in quantities of starting material is a
fundamental requirement for real-time
PCR based applications
to demonstrate this on the X9 system a
1.5 volt dilution series of human cdna
was run in triplicate on the X9 system
using the 19224 dynamic array IFC
the graph shown here shows amplification
curves from this run for an assay
targeting Gap pH
if you focused on the zoomed in area on
the right you can see that even 1.54
differences in starting material can be
clearly resolved using microfluidic
real-time PCR on the X9 system
demonstrating the ability of the system
to accurately detect even small
differences in starting material
quantities
with up to 9216 individual reactions on
the dynamic arrays it's important that
each reaction chamber performs uniformly
across the array
to demonstrate this aspect of
performance a 96-96 IFC was prepared
using 96 replicates of a single sample
and 96 replicants of a single assay and
was run on the X9 system
with this setup each of the 9216
reaction Chambers will contain the same
reaction components and will be expected
to generate the same CT value during
analysis
the plot shown here displays the
amplification occurs for 96 sample
replicates against the single Gap DH
assay from this run
a CT standard deviation of 0.06 CTS
between the replicates on a mean CT of
12.4 demonstrates an excellent
uniformity across reactions indicating
the ability to derive accurate results
for all reactions on a given IFC
individual measurements of accuracy and
uniformity demonstrate the basic
performance of the excellent system but
the true measurements of a real-time PCR
system are overall accuracy and
reproducibility
to examine these parameters two
experiments were conducted on the X9
system
first an 8.2-fold dilution series of
human cdna was run in triplicate of the
X9 system
results from this are shown in the plot
on the left
[Music]
analysis of mean CT values versus the
log of the concentration shows the
expected linear performance with the CT
difference of one cycle between beta
points
an r squared value of 0.998 and a slope
of negative 3.23 also correspond to
typical real-time PCR amplification
performance
taken together this data demonstrates
the accuracy of the X9 system
in the second experiment a human cdna
samples for many different tissue types
were run against a panel of 96 assays
from the standard biotools Advantage
immuno oncology gene expression panel
this panel contained 91 gene expression
targets relevant to immuno oncology
along with five reference targets used
to calculate normalized expression
two independent 96 96 ifcs will run and
the gene expression results of each IFC
were compared to each other
for the comparison normalized expression
values were calculated using the five
reference targets and the universal cdna
as a reference sample
normalized expression values were
compared across the two runs and the
results are plotted on the left hand
chart
each point represents the results of a
single sample an acid combination on
each IFC
in this example perfectly identical
results would result in all points
falling on a diagonal line passing
through the origin with a slope of one
when the two runs are compared they
generate an r squared value of 0.997 and
all points fall close to a line passing
through the origin with an actual slope
of 0.98
these results demonstrate highly
reproducible results across the two runs
and together this data demonstrates that
the X9 system is capable of generating
the highly accurate and reproducible
results expected with real-time PCR
performance in genotyping applications
require somewhat different parameters
than those required for real-time PCR
measurements that Target abundance or
gene expression however the underlying
requirements of accuracy and
reproducibility remain true
to demonstrate the performance of the X9
system in genotyping applications 96
snip genotyping assays were run against
92 samples and four negative controls on
a 96-96 IFC
the genotypes for each of these samples
for all 96 Snips were assessed were
previously determined from publicly
available sequencing and array data
the results of this run show that once
accounting for the four negative control
samples
that the eight of the
8827 snip genotypes calls made
8826 matched the expected genotype this
means that of all the individual
reactions on the dynamic array
99.95 of the reactions generated a call
and of those calls 99.99 match the known
genotype of the sample at that loci
overall these results demonstrate the
ability of the dynamic array on the
extent system to generate large volume
of genotyping data with accuracy and an
extremely high success rate of
individual reactions
microfluidic devices give the capability
to integrate several molecular biology
processes onto a single device
in addition to assembling individual
qpcr reactions other automated steps can
be incorporated into their design
the 9696 GT preamp by FCX is one such
IFC
this actually is capable of performing
an automated pre-amplification step
prior to qpcr detection to facilitate
the use of low concentrations of sample
input while maintaining the same ease of
use and high throughput of the other
standard biotools ifcs on the X9 system
the preamp ifcx allows automated
processing of up to 96 samples and 96
targets with inputs as low as 2.5
nanograms per microliter still
generating up to 9216 genotype calls in
a simple 2.5 hour hands-free run
thank you
[Music]
to demonstrate the performance of the GT
preamp ifcx Iran was performed with
replicate samples at 2.5 and 250
nanograms per microwator
these input concentrations result in a
total of 6.9 and 690 nanograms of DNA
loaded onto the IFC respectively
the snip genotyping cluster plots showed
typical performance for one of the 96
assays tested
Tech clustering and clear separation of
genotype calls denoted by the red green
and blue clusters demonstrates the
accurate results obtainable on the
preamp by FCX
furthermore zooming in on one cluster
demonstrates a tight overlap of results
regardless of starting input as shown by
the circles and diamonds indicating the
individual input concentrations
this demonstrates the GT preamp ifcx can
produce accurate sniff genotypes across
a wide range of input concentrations
demonstrating its utility for low input
DNA samples
overall microfluidic real-time PCR on
the X9 system can be implemented with
sample and assay throughput options to
meet multiple means the open nature of
the platform allows flexible content
design to mute a wide range of
application needs and microfluidic
real-time PCR reactions allow for
generation of deep data sets without
sacrificing the quality and precision
expected from real-time PCR
thanks for all your attention today I'll
pass it back to Luca for some closing
remarks
thank you very much Michael
we have learned today
can be implemented with sample and assay
throughput options to mean multiple
means the open nature of the platform
allows flexible content design to mute a
wide range of application needs and
microfluidic real-time PCR reactions
allow for generation of deep data sets
without sacrificing the quality and
precision expected from real-time PCR
thanks for all your attention today I'll
pass it back to Luca for some closing
remarks
thank you very much Michael
we have learned today how the X9
real-time PCR system can deliver more
data deeper insights with less efforts
exhibiting the blend of features and
characteristics
microfility covering such as a nanolita
reaction volume for cost Effectiveness
High throughput productivity with
individual reaction Simplicity and
integrated workflow for minimal operator
contribution that reduces human error
and minimize operational cost the X9 in
conjunction thank you Luca and Michael
for your Boost data generation capacity
while delivering Superior operational
efficiency and efficacy
thank you very much for attending this
session today if you want to learn more
about the X9 real-time PCR system please
visit our website or reach out to our
standard biotools representative in your
area thank you
thank you Luca and Michael for your
informative presentation if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
Michael is SNP genotyping an endpoint or
real-time PCR readout
yeah yes
um snip genotyping on the X9 system can
actually be analyzed in both real-time
and endpoint modes real-time data is
collected for all runs on the system and
then the user has the ability to analyze
that data in whichever manner they see
fit so in a real-time analysis mode the
user can analyze amplification curves
independently determine optimal cycles
for snip genotyping calls and utilize
all the capabilities of a real-time
analysis
or alternatively they can use the the
endpoint analysis as their application
needs arise
great thank you Michael which qpcr
detection eyes and detection method are
compatible with the X9 system
uh most primer and probe based detection
methods are compatible with the X9
system it uses rocks as a reference die
and then it supports Target detection in
fam and Vic or or related 404s uh
fluorophores
great thank you and it looks like my
next question is for Luca Luca during
the presentation you mentioned that the
system can load different Dynamic array
without Hardware modifications there
will be any collaboration needed and in
general any periodical collaboration is
needed or required by the manufacturer
oh okay uh good question so Dynamic
arrays are offered in different formats
and configuration to basically adapt to
the different laboratory needs or
shifting project requirements right so
all Dynamic arrays that are compatible
with the X9 system do not need or have
the necessity or impose the necessity to
modify the hardware components for
example no need to change the thermal
block or the optical system or make any
other adjustment when you move for
example from a 4848 format to a 96 96 or
a 19224 so the dynamic arrays are loaded
in conjunction with a dedicated
interface plate that ensure perfect
fitting and functioning of the overall
system both the
interface plate as well as the dynamic
array ifcs are coded and the actual X9
system automatically recognized the
format that you are loading on so in
regards of calibration and maintenance
X9 system does not require any specific
periodic recalibration and
you can immediately start using the
system after the installation as a the
platform is Factory calibrated already
for all compatible Dynamic arrays and
fluorophores now your Laboratory
um let's say operating procedures for
various reasons might require your
platforms to undergo periodical
proactive maintenance right so standard
biotools offers a variety of service
plans to best match individual
laboratory needs if I would say that if
you're interested to learn more I invite
you to visit our website or to reach out
to your local Representatives that
representative that can definitely
definitely definitely explain you in
great details all the options available
great thank you Luca you also mentioned
the capability to obtain Multiplex data
with single Plex Simplicity can you
expand on that
yep sure
um setting up a multiplex reaction can
be challenging and definitely time
consuming in particular as the number of
targets increase
in conventional Multiplex PCR
um usually two or more primer sets and
probes are included into the reaction
mix right so with this approach approach
it is a possible to amplify and detect
multiple Targets in the same Cube
Multiplex reaction on the other side can
be complicated to set up usually are
limited to two to six color often
requires a more expensive dedicated
super mixer and are in many instances
less sensitive compared to single Plex
equivalent
Furthermore with conventional real 10
PCR multiplexing
um it is usually not possible to other
or switch targets without the need of
reassessing and or redeveloping the
overall Multiplex assay with IFC
technology nx9 you can actually assay up
to 96 Target per sample sample in a
individual single Plex reaction
each assay can be added or switched or
removed based on needs and there is no
interaction across the different
amplifications furthermore I would say
that another thing to consider is that
by using Nano liter reaction volumes the
IFC IFC technology also help reducing an
experimental cost and save a pressure
sample for example I hope I answered the
question but in case more details are
needed or you want to learn more about
how X9 might be able to specifically
support your immediate uh say laboratory
need
um I encourage you to reach out to your
uh to our extremely competent and
knowledgeable system that I'm sure that
would be able to help you with more
details and specific for for your
specific cases
great thank you it looks like we have
one more question here how do the
microfluidics work on these plates how
do you pipette in the samples and the
probes
yeah so our micropolitic devices are
embedded into a plastic carrier that's
the same footprint as a 384 well plate
with the same well spacing as a 34 well
plate so the samples and probes are
individually pipetted into those inlets
on the on the carrier on on the IFC
typically using a multi-channel pipette
which eight channel pipettes make the
the pipetting very easy uh and that's
really it then you
um
put that microfluidic device into the
system and it the the X9 system itself
handles all of the micropolitic workflow
on the plate it pushes the samples and
assays in and and does all the
microfluidic processes automatically
great thank you so much it looks like
that brings us to the end of our q a
portion of the webinar Michael and Luca
do you have any final comments for our
audience today
thank you
foreign
I don't have any uh final comment I just
encourage all the audience or the people
that attended this webinar if there's
any additional question again I know
that already said that please reach out
to
um the sales representative of uh your
area and I will be happy to provide you
with all the details and more
information or specific information
based on your specific laboratory needs
so thank you again for joining us today
and uh have a good continuation of your
day
yes thank you again Luca and Michael for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor standard biotools
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I like to thank the
audience for joining us and for their
interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitting during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
that may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye